the Joe Rogan experience dude okay
here's here's something underrated
massively underrated Adam Sandler movies
sure Adam Sandler movies are
ridiculously underrated yeah
ridiculously underrated you're watching
me your daughter's dude they're
hilarious
yeah.he Adam Sandler has like I don't
know how many movies that are really
really funny but surprisingly funny like
like chuck and Larry
the one where he marries Kevin James for
benefits I didn't see that one dude it
is hilarious yeah there's some rough
moments in it where you watching you go
well you could never do this in transit
right it's one of those moves like if
somebody ever goes back on it and look
so like hey what the [ __ ] but ultimately
in the end it was like a really positive
movie but dude there are hilarious
moments in that movie where I'm like wow
this is really [ __ ] funny
yeah kingpin how kingpins [ __ ] great
no no it's different movie no no but I'm
not no I'm just saying kingpin there's
another movie yeah that I wish I could
go back and watch again but it's a
little too rough for my kids yeah rated
R right but that's another one like
people can you can forget how [ __ ]
funny that movie yeah I forgot how funny
those Adam Sandler movies are though
yeah I really did all right there's a
lot of a man waterboy is [ __ ]
hilarious yeah it starts off you're like
oh is this gonna be good cuz you know
it's 20 years ago or whatever the [ __ ]
it was well it's like I don't know dude
people watch Laurel and Hardy back then
and go like oh this is [ __ ] did it
all get dismissed as being too silly
it's like no those guys now you know
they accomplish something they provide a
style it's a style of movie it's a
absurdist ridiculous style of the Zohan
yeah it's a style of movie and he's so
good at it man really funny [ __ ] yeah
but it's weird like people have this
idea about what is acceptable funny and
not acceptable funny and he always got
pushed into this category of like you
know if if critics would pay
like if you look at a lot of them like
the Rotten Tomatoes like 14% 15% and
then the audience is like 97 yeah right
dude they're just missing what it is
yeah you can't want the Ramones to be
Pink Floyd mm-hmm you know Pink Floyd
has their own style and the Ramones had
a way more like rock n roll high school
it was a simpler it's a different thing
right it's a different thing Yeah right
Adam Sandler movies are their own thing
yeah the [ __ ] hilarious man well like
five of them over the last week it kind
of goes into the genre of like Lorne
Michaels has never given a [ __ ] about
critics you know and they weren't they
take sketches and characters from the
show that are funny and starting with
the first one must have been the Blues
Brothers or Animal House and they just
started spinning out [ __ ] movies from
what they knew were were the kernels of
something that was very funny
they started there and so a lot of them
are you know even like it's pat like you
go back and watch the movies they're
[ __ ] hilarious
as long as you go in with the right
mindset Tommy Boy I watched two oh yeah
you know I never saw Tommy Boy before
yeah I'm like why didn't I ever see this
it's hilarious yeah I mean it's
Wharton's in that right yeah
Schwartz it sports ins in all these
movies yeah he's into everything he's in
chuck and Larry he's like one of the
best parts of Chuck him Larry yeah he's
amazing Nick Swardson is [ __ ]
hilarious
he's really really really funny yeah
dude when he was like when he first came
to New York I can't imagine he was more
than 19 or 20 years old and he was like
hanging around with you know all the
comics and he was just like already as
funny as everybody else he already had
the confidence and just like the
knowledge about he's a really [ __ ]
brilliant guy well he's just got a style
of comedy - that's his yeah you know
like his kind of punchline it just Matt
it's him
you know he knows how to do it and he
understands how to put diary in a
punchline every one of these Adam
Sandler movies again so is Rob Schneider
at Rob Schneider's and every one of them
there's so many source movies where they
culturally-appropriate you're like oh my
god yeah
today Rob Schneider plays it's like
really really stereotypical Japanese guy
he has Japanese eyes on like they did
they put makeup to change his eyes to
you look more like a Japanese guy he's
got a crazy bowl haircut laughs never do
that today it's hilarious yeah but it's
like why can't you do that today like
it's it's just a character it's supposed
to be over the top and ridiculous yeah
it just doesn't mean everyone in the
race is horrible it's just not this is
an individual that this guy chose to
play yeah but you I don't think you
could do it anymore
[Applause]